PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
This week, we're
talking about the PerfKit
Benchmarker, Kubernetes
updates, and new table
formats for Dataproc.
I am Priyanka Vergadia,
and welcome to "This Week
in Cloud," where we serve
you the lowest-latency news.
We've just expanded PerfKit
Benchmarker, the open source
tool that makes network
performance benchmarking faster
and easier.
PerfKit Benchmarker now
supports a broader range
of network performance
tests and lets
you view the results
in Google Data Studio.
The goal is to help you
predict the performance
impact of moving workloads to
and across different clouds.
As Google Kubernetes Engine
moved from version 1.12 to 1.15
over the past year, we made
several security changes
to the platform to improve
security behind the scenes--
changes like paring
down controls
to only what your
application actually needs,
and improving the defaults,
and, of course, maintaining
the "GKE Hardening Guide"
so that you can always
find the best advice for the
security of your clusters.
And speaking of
Kubernetes, it's never
a bad time for a Kubernetes
best practices guide.
This one covers Kubernetes
namespaces, readiness probes
for health checks,
controlled deployment,
and more, because
containerized app management is
a favorite of ours for
deploying and managing
production apps at scale.
Dataproc is a
fully-managed service
for running Apache
Hadoop ecosystem
software in the cloud, and we've
just added new table formats
to support workloads that
need ACID transactions, data
versioning, schema enforcement,
and schema evolution.
Check out our new
guide on these formats,
and let us know what you think.
If you want to read more
about these announcements
or see a full list,
check out the link.
Any thoughts or ideas, leave
us a comment or tweet us.
We will see you in the cloud.